well good evening
[Music]
okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to this full council meeting
i'm sorry uh
very versus january before we actually
get into the agenda can i welcome
carrie ann woodhouse the new
representative from northern carrie is
just over here if you just have to wait
so everyone will see who you are yeah
thank you very much
so as i say welcome counselors and
welcome to those members of the public
that are watching on youtube this
evening
[Music]
apologies from councillor ancient
councillor craigie
item two is the coastal minutes of the
13th december
i'll run through them a page at a time
six
seven
[Music]
eight nine
ten
eleven
[Music]
and twelve
so i'm gonna have to propose them as a
true record thanks for watching
actually
all in favor please sure
[Music]
okay and again
and extensions
[Music]
contributions we have
one public speaker registered dr teresa
kingsley director of alcantara
communications to speak about standards
in public life
you have your three minutes starting
whenever
i'm here to appeal to councillors as
local politicians
to stand up for the ethical standards in
public life which was set out by the
nolan committee
integrity honesty openness
objectivity
selflessness accountability
and leadership
during the various lockdowns over the
last two years
torridge residents made huge sacrifices
in order to limit the spread of covet
and protect the vulnerable and the nhs
businesses have had to close or severely
limit the trade they do
those that did not like at least two
hubs in biddeford were given strict
fines
now we find that the very people who are
asking us to make those sacrifices
and imposing those times were
persistently and brazenly breaking their
own goals
at least 15 i think it's now gone up to
16 events in westminster are currently
under investigation
it seems that there is a culture of the
illegal party from socializing which our
leaders did nothing to halt but rather
joined in
this is double standards hypocrisy as if
the laws are for us the little people
not the big dogs of government
bad enough but even more serious is that
our leader lied about it he assured
parliament that no rule had been broken
when they clearly had
when evidence emerged that he'd been out
to the parties he said he thought that
he was attending a work event
which is about as believable as going to
barnard castle to check her eyesight
some people will say well
lots of people bent the rules and
perhaps some of us did
but a leader must model the sort of
behaviour they expect from the public
otherwise the public will say why should
we bother and that way the rule of law
has broken down
tens of thousands of people here in
torridge put ourselves out to comply for
the good of the community
when we find that our leaders have been
fragrant flagrant breakers of their own
laws we're naturally angry
how can we trust our government if they
allow this to happen
ideally i would appeal to my mp
but for the last year the only reply
i've had from him is an automated
message saying that he's very busy
politicians are being brought into
disrepute
and that is bad for democracy which is
why i'm bringing this matter to you
as local politicians
because you surely are better than that
i think that you are committed
to honesty integrity openness and
accountability and public life
i appeal to you
to take a stand against the appalling
dereliction of those standards that we
currently see at the top of government
your three minutes are virtually up nice
and you could wind up very quickly
please do something make a statement
write a letter above all distant tourist
district council from the calamitous
leadership which is bringing shame on
our country and on our democracy
okay item four on the agenda is
declaration of interest so
you all know the score by now if there
are any matters of interest that come up
on the agenda you need to
speak up and
act accordingly
item five is uh agreement of agenda
items part one and two there are part
two items
[Music]
could i suggest or propose that uh item
21 is still within part one
and view of openness and transparency
[Music]
um just i'd like to have it minuted my
disappointment disappointment that my
next promotion was refused to go into
this evening's agenda i feel so strongly
about the recent revelations of the
parties in number 10 and really wanting
to emphasize concern
[Music]
thank you
sorry uh it was proposed and seconded
that the part two item was taken apart
was that correct yes i have a show of
hands who's in support of that
and abstentions
but
rest assured as i've done on many
occasions and i've made just about the
whole of the residence of alcohol aware
of this
i will view it later as i add to
a previous hearing which was a giraffe
quite frankly
when a counselor
has got to do an foi sar information i'm
entitled to by law it's a
disgrace and foi is a freedom of
information and
what
okay
sit down and be quiet until your time
when you're asked to speak i said what
about you thank you thank you
uh
item ships
especially brought forward by the
direction of the chair i've got a letter
which i need to read out this is a
letter
which
has been sent by the
group leaders
i'll get to their names in a second so
letter of uh letter to the sheriff count
full council urgent matters here
controversially we thought as the five
group leaders of the council imperative
that we write to you as chair of the
council to express our deep concerns
that the behavior of one of the
council's elected members comes to the
forward is becoming hugely damaging to
the reputation and perception of the
council its elected members and staff to
the outside world
at the last full council meeting on the
13th of december of 21 councillor ford
stood up in the public part of the
meeting to make several accusations and
allegations against fellow members and
officers and officers in particular
attention and the gulf and stacy dory
our head of legal and governance
the council's monitoring officer
we need to put on public record that
these accusations and allegations are
completely unfounded and unsubstantiated
we cannot continue to condone such
intimidating and bullying behavior
towards our staff and members
council of fort has been asked on
numerous occasions
that if he has any factual evidence to
back up his stories that allegations can
be investigated but he has failed to do
so
councillor ford instead chooses to use
the opportunity and platform of our
council meeting to continually and
publicly abuse
members and staff and it must be stopped
we have discussed these matters with the
chief executive and he is deeply
concerned the damaging effect this is
having on the council staff their morale
and in particular the health and
well-being of those staff being
indiscriminately targeted by this
unacceptable behavior
more widely a reputational impact this
will have on the council if not properly
addressed and refuted which could lead
those outside of the council believing
in these stories and these stories the
chief executive asked that we as the
most senior political leaders of the
council take action to address this as a
matter of urgency
as a council we have achieved a huge
amount over the last two and a half
years through the monumental efforts of
a hard-working staff and members which
council reform seems intent on trying to
undermine
we want to be accounts who have seemed
to want to achieve and deliver our
ambitious plans with senior officers
staff and members working together side
by side with mutual respect
we therefore respect respectfully ask
the chair to ensure that comes to the
forward is stopped from making such
unfounded statements in our council
meeting and if deemed necessary be
removed from the meeting
and this is signed by councillor ken
james the leader of the council
that's simon newton leader of the
conservative group
councillor
cheryl caldwell-hunker leader of the
liberal democrat group and seda brenton
the leader of the labor group and cancer
pinnacle of state leader of the non-line
group
so
clearly you're not in the same way of
thinking
thank you
okay moving on to item seven
to answer questions submitted under
procedural rule a9 there are three
questions submitted one from
pennsylvania two from councillor ford
the answers
have been tabled as required under the
constitution i believe there are copies
on the table in front of you now special
counsel
i've uh have your response uh do you or
do you want to ask a supplemental
question um
goes ahead and his solar array will
effectively be switched off for eight
months of the year resulting in the loss
of his zero carbon business i'm
particularly concerned with the specific
application because i'm told that the
assessment conducted for the outline
planning commission was inaccurate and
used the wrong measurements and
dimensions which did not provide a valid
assessment of the effects i therefore
asked for the council to commission a
valid report into it using the correct
data before they progress the
application forward
well clearly there should be a separate
response to that because that
information isn't available tonight
one of the
uh the other
questions
uh tabled by councillor ford
you've got a response there
a written question submitted under
procedure rule a9 how much did the jack
hagar haggardly report across the
council you've got a written response in
front of you i think everyone's got a
copy in front of them yeah
this seems to me a pity that we had to
spend
677 pounds
[Music]
um
actually this is the follow-up question
yeah
i might say it could have been more
actually but waste of money
um
organizing and that might become obvious
um
basically a simple question
to
audit and governance
[Music]
did he have the document you received
back from seven kennedy council of the
sentinels
of documentation
did he have that in his judgment that
clearly um
did you also subsequently show him the
email in the cough and
tidy i had a forehead i've got it all
i've got fire records and i've got an
orbit trail let's just put all the rest
of you out so i want to know where the
ants are and all the evidence held by
poets referencing photographs that were
used and told to him he witnessed it tom
vanstrom was there
in the office when i asked sean carney
not only would be shawn to put a proper
photographic thing together about the
serious health and safety issue in the
bottom of the tripway network
for whistle blowing i might as well pee
in it or take a po
yeah well we'll deal with this
separation we'll get back to you on that
coaching forum
[Music]
yes
so the next question i asked the
beginning
[Music]
you can't deal with it
[Music]
the question should be directed directly
to him
[Music]
okay moving on and closer to item eight
on the agenda
uh one more than devon presentation
i want to receive a presentation from
one more than devon
[Music]
coming forward
i'm not exactly sure how long your
presentation is
scheduled to be but i would just
definitely ask you to try and keep it
within 15 minutes of the characters
thank you everybody um i'm andrew
beecham i'm partnerships and gpas on
lead at northern devon trust and
program manager for one northern devon
i'm downhill i'm the chief officer for
ttbs based in philippines
uh hopefully you can see i'm a police
officer
toby davies local president commander
for north and west
and thank you for having us today and
we're here to talk to you about the one
communities and the high flow programme
um in one northern devon
um so i'm sure a number of you are aware
of um the one community's um approach
and they're a number in so we've got one
communities in each of them
[Music]
um so the one community is um
there's seven one communities across the
northern devon um
and four in
north devon and three in torridge
and they've been going for various
amounts of time
and
the whole
ethos of a one community
is that the communities that know
and live in the places
really have more power to work together
in partnership with the public sector
some of them have private sector
involvement in them residents
faith groups so everybody getting
together to work on local problems
and identified by their local community
but using very much their local assets
so building on what they've already got
in terms of the voluntary sector
residents and everything else
so as you can see from this slide um
there's one community started back in
2013 and have been growing since
um we've got
six towns um across northern devon and
one parish which is borington parish
um
and part of the integral to the one
community is the community developer
role so that's the paid role
um their role is to bring together the
local plans
so they have been integral in organizing
local engagement
across the communities to find out what
matters to communities what's important
to them
and they've also been integral in
mapping the assets that are available in
each of those communities
and
pulling together the meetings and making
sure that all the key stakeholders are
involved so hopefully a number of you
are involved in those community-run
communities themselves
and so that's and torrington
100
one atlantic which started life as one
biddeford but has now expanded and then
very recently the holes were the
community involvement forum as well
[Music]
um so
there there is a cost involved in the
community developer role but we wanted
to just talk to you very briefly about
the value of that role
so some of the things and you'll have
seen in the report that was recently
circulated that we've highlighted some
of the work of one atlantic and
torrington 100 and some of the very
recent work in holesworthy
and very recently we had partners and
contribute some funding so that we could
understand what the mental health needs
and well-being needs were in those
communities and so the community
developers have spent a lot of time
engaging with local residents to find
out
um how their mental health has been
affected over the last couple of years
and most importantly what would help
um and then as a result of that the
community developer in partnership with
the rest of the of the community
starts looking at developing
provision to meet to fill those gaps
and so a number of them have set up
things like men's sheds there's been
active lifestyle groups
um there's been all sorts of um
different things really based on what
that community said is needed and what's
already there that we can build on
and so
one of the things that we wanted to talk
to you about is whether we could develop
a sort of stronger partnership with
torridge district council and if
possible if you could consider
um funding apart funding a joint
investment proposal with the rest of the
public sector organizations across north
devon and torridge so um
what we put down there was that actually
if each of the district councils um for
north elementary put in 10 000 pounds
um we and the town councils were also
going to invest it as well along with
health who have committed a hundred
thousand pounds
um just under a hundred thousand pounds
to support this but if we work together
and we would actually be able to fulfill
that role for um another year
and that was the role itself was really
important during covid with the
community response there and obviously
for volunteering and supporting with
that
and
i won't take questions now i'll pass on
to toby to talk about high flow and then
we'll come back to questions if that's
okay
[Music]
good evening everybody uh i say toby
davies um i wanted to
apologize that's my my phone so i
um one of the
projects one issues that stemmed off one
of them is is high flow i'm going to
talk about that tonight because we're
looking for funding it's like dragon's
density is now i'm afraid i'm sorry
but um so we are we're working
with some of the most complex
chaotic highest demand individuals uh in
in north in the northern devon area not
including torrid as well that are
putting the most pressure on on public
services so the partner agencies
including yourselves
uh work together cross-reference who is
putting most demand across the system
and then we've agreed to take a certain
cohort to then work to try and address
some of those those issues so
the initiative is very much about trying
to find a much more joined up way
of working with these people and we're
calling it a team around the person
we're trying to avoid
the situation which in the past which is
about one individual has to go to six
seven eight different agencies share the
same story again and doesn't know how to
navigate the system so we put a team
around that person
and put simply it's about breaking the
cycle we keep getting the same people
with the doors of custody same people
going through the calls the same people
going through a e going to gp surgeries
alcohol services drug services housing
services
so it's all about and this is key
addressing the root causes of those poor
behaviors all those dependencies
on on services
and so we all know that obviously the
drug and alcohol and mental health
issues that are there but virtually
every single
situation will link back to some form of
trauma
in childhood or adulthood whether that's
you know sexual abuse physical abuse
neglect
and it's key to this is trying to
address those particular issues to stop
that repeat behavior so
the people talking about are generally
obviously very very vulnerable and one
of the key parts this a lot of this
we've got the services we've got people
it's about coordinating those people so
the initiative has a high flow
caseworker which works with individuals
ensures that team then uh then come
around to provide that support signpost
take people to where they where they
need to be
so if you go to the next slide okay
so look you you if you where you can see
that you've got great eyesight sidecar
but i i'll describe it to you anyway
demand is down massively since this has
been in place over the last 18 months to
two years significant reduction demand
significant uh savings have been found
but you know for me that's not what it's
about
so yes
that's important but actually
the real story behind this is the change
that we've made to some of those
people's lives
um
and if you look in the report that was
sent out there are examples there are no
names we can't leave enough to leave
that would identify anybody but one of
the examples for me
is there's a homeless
female who
had come into contact with police within
a year hundreds of contacts with police
as a defender sometimes as a as a victim
also huge level of contact with health
services housing services d.a services
drug services alcohol services in fact
any service that's pretty much given in
north uh northern devon
she's probably had some involvement and
we best describe she was an absolute
mess at that particular time very nearly
died
as a result of her addictions
very unhealthy relationships that she
was involved
in as well and that addiction
um just exacerbated some of her very
anti-social behaviors so very visible to
certain parts of the community and she
wouldn't despite singular agency trying
to she just would not or couldn't
understand how to uh to get that help
huge demand and that is a great example
of where a high flow the caseworker
comes in
offers a different an alternative
approach takes that
that individual takes them to the places
they need to go because they people
won't go
on their own that individual is now off
the streets
is now housed that individual has now
had loads of support around their drug
and alcohol uh addiction
the relationship side of stuff they got
a much healthier understanding of what
they need to do in terms of maintaining
healthy relationships
and whilst not absolutely completely
clear to those contacts we're talking
from up here and we're talking now down
there to contact but the reality is she
is in a much much better place so for me
um it's a relatively small sum we're
talking about here because a lot of the
services are out there already
we're asking
and for all the partners that are
involved in this and you're one of the
the obviously the key partners in here
to put in
12 000
that would then sustain this project and
enable to grow the project so we take
even more people on to the initiative
over the next two years and in my mind
make a really big difference to uh to
people's lives if we're looking at the
money for the people that are in there
for every quid that's spent
the the analysis is saying that two
pound forty is being saved so what
you're investing is ultimately looking
to to to save as well so
my plea is
12
12 000. i think that's probably a good
time to bring questions
on both aspects
now i'm sure we've got lots of people
that want to ask questions
please first
thank you
thank you chairman um as lead member for
health and well-being i have regular
contacts with toby
i know a little bit more about
the story that he's saying
but suffice to say this person
who had these say 300 visits a year
is now gone from the debit side to the
credit side because that person is
actually putting back into society
and that's a massive turnaround
and it's an ongoing improvement and we
hope this person will go forward even
further in life
because they have a lot more to give
if you think about how often we need the
police
and other
services
and how stretched they are
if you imagine that they've got one
intervention
almost per day or five a week
that frees up a massive amount of police
time
so this
gem
of
12 000 pounds
can be the mustard seed that's
flourishes out and puts back money into
our coffers makes officer time more
available to our communities
i propose
that we put this money into this
worthwhile project thank you chairman
yeah whichever way this goes uh this
evening it's obviously we need to go
back to cmr or probably via
just a report and let's be a report to
see in our islands we can't make a
decision tonight but we can
uh decide if we wish to refer to cnr i
think coach mckenzie you've got your
hand a lot of that
yeah i'm not going to be here
but my second everything he says
if we could make
be
a
worth doing so um it's not only the
police it's the emergency services as um
ale and the ambulance service and
there's all sorts of social services
i've got a couple of clients that are
involved with high flow and the
differences made to their lives is
immeasurable um
one bad outcome but that is nothing to
do with my flow that was just purely uh
tragic um
but yeah
i've got to support this wholeheartedly
and for every pound spent
thank you um
yeah sounds really great this uh i
wouldn't mind giving some of my
counselor allowance to this but can i
ask um have you approached the british
trust in biddeford because
we actually we get a lot of applications
and there are some other british trusts
here tonight we get a lot of
applications through social services for
probably the people in your
program
uh with all sorts of problems um it
might be worth approaching the british
office because it would help us save
money as well so it's online if you want
to apply
thank you i think we have potentially
through the one community
might have done might have done that but
not for not for high flows
[Music]
any other speakers
yes
um so with regards to that reduction in
demand what that actually looks like as
to how many people you've supported in
that time through the hive service
and
given that it's been collected or
created within the last 18 to 12 months
do you think that would perhaps have had
an effect on some of these services as
well
and yeah cleanse that one so the
we were only able to collect the data
um for
six of the individuals and during that
12-month period so that
data is actually for those those six
individuals
um and that's just for a 12 month period
rather than the full 18 months period
that that
that high flow has been going
um and
what and that doesn't represent all of
our partners data we haven't quite been
able to collect the data from two
district councils yet just through the
difficulties in trying to understand
what the demand actually is and the
reduction would be but basically it
compares
the 12 months prior to the intervention
and the numbers of interventions with
the police saying etc um with the with
the numbers of interventions
during
the cost during the intervention
and it just compares it like for like um
in terms of code it has had an impact in
obviously the level of support
we were able to give um during the
actual lockdowns and and our high flow
case worker did feel that that had an
impact and but i couldn't really tell
you whether it had a bit more wider
impact than that
i've got one question myself
before i come onto you cancer painting
um
you mentioned one bitty food which is
i was around 10 council said the 10
council when one one uh one biddeford um
was was started but over the last
obviously everyone blames coffee but
over the last
couple of years at least probably three
years
pretty cool but it just doesn't matter
it just started out and i'm just
intrigued to find out how
uh one video's like morphed into one
atlantic so i've never heard the term
before
[Music]
i think the key to that has been that
that community developer
um
they
they have
been a catalyst in the community
so we we changed from one video to the
atlantic to normally to the communities
that sat outside the town and probably
didn't feel included but by the name one
biddeford but when you get the community
developer and they're out there they're
working with social prescribers they're
working with all the other organizations
the charities the
um even the private sector there they're
identifying the gaps and
it's the energy that comes from that
individual that that has made this work
and i think that that came before when
we were in that first lockdown kobe that
their response their knowledge their
relationships that they've built up
through through the atlantic um really
made that a success um so
every single person that's been involved
expanded that one individual which is
why you know we're here tonight to talk
about it because it's so important okay
thank you thank you
well thank you chair just to follow
directly from your question
um one atlantic i i read the
documentation that came through to us
very late this afternoon um interesting
to read but you mentioned it goes from
northern western hill to heartland
now my ward includes abbotsham alwington
uh
where does the other rural areas fit in
here it seems very tone-centric
and doesn't pick up so where does the
referring come in and who refers to
certain individuals who are lucky enough
because quite frankly when i look at
care leavers
youngsters put into care i mean i think
there's about 64
go on at some point in their lives into
prison which is a huge course on society
surely this money will be better spent
better
directly on care leavers
than it would be having another uh
project set up alongside and secondly i
see you're saving 2.40 for every pound
spent
could you put that business plan to a
bank manager and actually finance it
yourself
i i'll i'll start the first bit the
first point is just to be clear here's
two there are two separate um obviously
presentations there so the high flow
uh which is comes off the back of one
northern devon which covers the whole
the one northern devon sorry which
covers the holy area that covers the
whole patch okay so the whole of our of
our area is covered and clients can come
from anywhere within that patch the way
that the the one approach is set up is
probably best for journalism
yeah so currently the one communities
are quite town-centric as you say
um but what we've absolutely tried to do
is so we've we're starting um a
community around the person approach so
in high flow we've talked about a team
around the person one of the things we
started to do in our communities is take
referrals as you say
um and and they can come from people
coming home from hospital they can come
from a gp say i'm a bit worried about
this person could have volunteered
perhaps go in and check and it doesn't
matter where they're from it might be
organized from the center of the town
but whatever that rural community is and
we will make sure that that one
community will access that and the other
thing just just to say on it is that
although high flow is you know quite
dramatic in what it does and it's quite
on that end of the scale what we feel
like with one communities deal they're
very much at the beginnings of the
preventative work so if we can support
people and communities to be really
resilient we hope that they never get to
the point of needing a high flow
intervention so they're kind of two ends
of the scale but very much about
supporting individuals within um
communities
can i just just add on that that
the point of the one approach is that
you're saying um but what we fund it but
who who are we because the one approach
is just a collection of partners and you
sit
within that what the one approach tries
to do is try to see issues like this and
say we can all collectively work
together and the only way we can
collectively work together is by going
out and collectively funding it as well
because if someone if some parts of the
system fund it and others don't there i
guess there's a bit there's a fairness
issue around it as well so we're that's
part of this we've come together and
said you know what we think this is
really important it's delivering
something different
actually we feel that everyone should
chip in a little bit okay can i just
supplementary to that chair yes
very briefly is this funding then seed
core so it's initial
funding and then it will be
self-financing
from a future stage no it's a good it's
a good question and i think that we've
had this discussion because of course i
would love to say we sustain this and
maintain this is because business as
usual but the approach at the moment is
every couple of years we need to go out
to then so we've deliberately gone for
two years so that we can keep this going
for another two years and i hope that
the success will speak for itself again
and then we can then go back and keep
and keep asking the question and i guess
you would want to see that it's still
delivering as well
thank you for the responses
the question you want to ask another
question thank you um
can i ask you
how do people get on this scheme do you
put them on it or do you ask them is it
voluntary because
i mean the biggest
uh
load of complaints i get in biddeford
and i suspect i speak to all the british
accountants here is the alcoholics down
and busy hell walk and in jubilee square
can you actually tell them they're going
to come this or aren't they bad enough
yet how does it work
um so so we've got a mechanism whereby
any of the high flow partners can come
and put forward somebody to go on onto
high flow and we it's normally what we
call the most intensive service users
and so what we look at and i think
torridge council have put forward people
and to go on the high flow program and
we tend to see whether they're
high intensity users across the services
those those ones will sort of get to the
top of the list
and then
importantly it is consent led so
somebody can't be made to go on the
scheme and they have to you know we ask
for their permission we tell them what
the support is and i don't think we've
had anyone actually refuse it we've had
people that you know have moved away or
it's not been appropriate but actually
people do appreciate that having
services
brought into coordination around them is
actually going to be really good for
them
yeah
i think it'd be fair to say that people
we've got a vet the person who's got
that the role hyphen case work and katie
simpson has done a brilliant job is very
persuasive and she's managed to bring
people on who have not engaged in others
so it is it does depend on a very strong
individual but has brought people in who
would never otherwise have engaged with
some of the services so
but it is still it has to be consent
that there are other projects or we're
involved in which i won't do right now
obviously
which are not consent-led we might do
that work behind the scenes and this is
not one
okay well it's i think country newton
proposed it and council
do you wish to second that proposal
indeed yes
the other way
one on the other side
[Music]
in favor please
thank you very much
thank you ladies and gentlemen
i would
urge you to contact the british trust as
well because um
[Music]
perhaps you won't want as much money
over time
okay item nine on the agenda is uh a
gambling act statement principles pages
13 to 53 and janet williams is going to
come forward and present this
you're already
[Music]
[Music]
authority must find law prepare a
statement of the principles that they
propose to apply in exercise and
expansion under the gambling act this
statement must be reviewed every three
years and the current statement
principles expired yesterday
this updated statement has been subject
to review and updated in line with the
latest guidance it's gone through full
consultation and there's been no
representations
or objections to what has been proposed
and as such uh the statements given has
been recommended for approval by the
chair of the licensing committee and the
statement is given in full in the
appendix report and i put this forward
for approval by members and happy to
take any comments or questions
councillor mckenzie
yeah um i propose that we do accept the
mistaken principles as they are um
we have been able to discuss this um
licensing committee because one time
you're in for a second time
together so that needs to be the
wednesday if anybody wants to go on
training so they can start they'd be
most welcome so what proposals do
[Music]
please
[Music]
um
item 10 on the agenda
uh
devon carbon plan pages 54 to 57.
what are you doing
thank you thank you
in february last year members approved
county council's interim carbon plan
as part of their process to develop
their final carbon plan they sought
further discussions and consideration of
some of the bigger elements
of potential carbon reduction for the
county
they progressed this by way of the
residence climate assembly and the
details of that process are given in the
report
the issues considered by them were the
following
uh what should be the rule of onshore
wind in devon renewable energy strategy
what needs to be done to improve less
endeavor and what would be the best ways
of encouraging or requiring people to
retrofit their homes properties or
business premises to reduce carbon
emissions
the outcome recommendations from the
climate assembly given the appendix to
the report these have been reviewed
cross-referenced with the interim plan
already in place and a final response
given to each of these recommendations
again included in the appendix
so firstly the request from devon county
council put to memphis today is to prove
that the outcome of the demon climate
systems assembly as given in the
appendix one is included in the next
round of their public consultation
and the report has also been taken to
tdc's member climate working group we've
put forward with the reputation that
these measures go to public consultation
but they've also added additional
comments which are given in section 5 of
the report if these additional comments
are endorsed by this committee these
will be forwarded to devon county
council and their own accounting
department as part of our local fan
review
and again i'm happy to take any comments
or queries on the report
[Music]
[Music]
online
installation
i think this would be a very good
service that we could offer to the
public
it's if you think you're just going to
put some solar panels for example
on your properties think twice about it
it's not as simple as it sounds but
starter is one of the things we've just
discovered you know
our house is a great car neutral um
so you can register
that you've got them
with them your provider you're the
person you you do have your electricity
from
they don't tell you
of course you don't because they're
losing money if they tell you you do get
obviously a substantial reduction
uh we we've weren't done that and then
we were behind time and then it set up
all sorts of barriers
to do with they would have to be sure
that it was installed by a registered
installer which is another thing if you
think you're going to just screw your
own
you're not gonna you won't get away with
that
so there is a
wealth of
actual red tape and i think that would i
don't know whether it applies to
external planning as well but i think
that we could as a authority
offer that sort of guidance or at least
signpost people into that direction
before they they rush up and do it
would that be the question
um yes that's certainly something we
could be put off and i am aware of some
of those issues that council grandson
has as mentioned and but that that might
be something that the member climate
group could look into in more detail and
bring something back
any other speakers
[Music]
all in favor please sure
[Music]
on those again
and abstentions
11 housing provision
update report which is pages 78 to 80
and the leader ken james and chief
executive will present this report
[Music]
thank you chair i'll start
the leader
and so a very short report
um
as an update report so you'll know that
housing is one of the integral parts of
your strategic plan
you will recall we had a couple of
workshops or member workshops
with a gentleman from our consultancy
from those workshops who identified a
number of actions and the actions are
set out in section two of the report
there on page
78.
so on the bottom of that page then we've
started
uh
identifying and reporting how we
progress progressing and the actions uh
in progress against uh
what
to deliver
and then that follows over on page 79 so
this work being done around the
viability assessments we've been
incorporating to the joint global plan
review development which obviously the
the first meeting of that joint
committee took place
last friday
probably one of the bigger areas of work
we've started
is undertaking a
look at all the land
assets that storage owns to establish
whether any of that land is ideal for
um
development property development
um so that that part has started we'll
then take a look to determine whether
it's suitable into in planning terms and
at that point then we bring
those details to a future member
workshop where members can look through
each of them and identify whether
they're
suitable sites to take forward and do a
lot more work in terms of developing
them at that point then with their
continued discussions with holmes
england sean's already had some initial
discussions with them about funding some
of the costs of those schemes
[Music]
um you'll note from the report uh we
applied for some grant funding for the
local government association we were
initially
unsuccessful but we've been successful
in the in the second round
they've allocated 25 000 pounds for us
to progress this project
uh the report
requests um consideration be given to
match funding after the further 25 000
pound although i would suggest we uh
revisit that
specific recommendation obviously in
light of our budget discussions at cnr
this morning
you've heard that obviously we need or
we've had requests for funding for cab
we had requests for funded here tonight
i think we ought to look at those in the
realms uh all together so i would
suggest uh
in the coming weeks uh
have you seen any questions i think the
leader wants to speak first
yes
thank you
very much
steve has come across there i sat on the
housing uh group
[Music]
trying to do something collectively
within devon county so there's all
knowing
district councils trying to come up with
their own schemes and work together for
a scheme to go forward
so we need to be active we need to
this is high priority
as steve said we returned most unusually
we applied for 20 thousand got turned on
and then we got off at 25 so i'm not
going to follow everybody else into the
bedroom i will just ask that we refer it
to ons internal for them to look at
whether there is that funding within the
budget or whether we can find that
because it is such a high biology for
this area
um and we need to be proactive
we look like we're being left behind by
the other eight district councils so i'd
like to support the recommendation
i counted the question i wanted to speak
first yeah i'd like to second that um
literally minutes before i came to this
meeting i had a phone call
somebody who's the landlord's throwing
them out they've got to be out by
february 11th
nothing in this area is going to live in
uh absolutely desperately it's not the
only phone call i've had like that i've
had quite a few and you only have to go
online to see
what's going on um i was really pleased
in our report under section two there
review the process of liability
assessment
and if you look down a bit further we
get the
uh viability assessments now on plans
took me a few years to get it at least
it's there now
um but i would ask uh in the light of
what happened at the last planning
meeting we need to look at this very
quickly
we had two very large applications in
biddeford
where one was offering five percent
affordable and the other 10
that was up to 15 after the district
value even he didn't think it was
good but when we don't seem to be
meeting our 30 ever and the one thing i
think if we are going ahead with this
and we are looking at these viability
studies can i make a plea
that
there are two things really firstly we
need to ask devon county how they arrive
at their figures
for their improvement to the roads
they just seem to think of a number and
double it
i mean we had one to the last meeting
actually where they were asking for
money
for a scheme which is basically finished
and
there's this bottomless pit of hayward
road roundabout which money seems to
disappear into and none of us understand
how they arrive in these figures and it
does affect the number of affordable
houses the developer can offer and the
other thing is and i know i'm probably
we're sitting in the wind here that the
one thing we don't get in viability
studies is the cost of the land
which in many cases the absolute
prime thing you need to know i don't i
think council hicks will tell me they
don't have to tell us and they won't
tell us um but we really do need to know
that and i wonder if we couldn't
look at that thank you
comes
[Music]
yeah just following on from council
christie's viability observations it
seems to me that the viability process
should be looked at right at allocation
stage during the
planning
process in the local plan really rather
than
the latest stage
whether that's possible but
another point the other thing i wanted
to ask um high priority high priority is
being given to this so can we is there a
schedule of dates that we can be given
as to no target dates as to when each
stage is going to progress
thank you thank you
so we have a detailed delivery of
starting to develop a detailed delivery
plan behind this obviously we recognize
it's a priority however our immediate
priority for this these coming months
are
implementing the leisure uh service
into active tolerance so that's got a
deadline which we can't miss so that's
been our priority over the last couple
of months and these current couple
months so we recognize it's a it's a
priority so we've as i said we started
work on looking at our assets our land
and we hope to have that finalized by
the end of march and then we can start
bringing some further information to
members
okay well thank you james poster thanks
for chris he's second hit uh for no
other
questions people wish to ask i'll call
for a vote and support those all those
in favor please share
[Music]
[Music]
thank you chair um very briefly
because hopefully this is a formality
tonight because the actual changes to
the committee have already been agreed
by full council but to formally amend
our constitution i need the agreement of
fall council so i'm asking for
permission tonight to add the joint
planning policy committee um to the
constitution which was agreed by paul
council on the 5th of october
with some changes to the terms of
reference to the harbour board working
group to update it to allow free
non-elected representatives to sizzle
the harbour group
which was formally approved by full
council on the 1st of november
and an update um to the terms of
reference for the standards committee
historically we had two independent
persons and now that's been increased to
free so i need an agreement from full
council tonight to formally update the
constitution to reflect those changes
okay i'll propose that from the chair
to what's in secondary much for watching
[Music]
[Music]
thank you councillors our current
external auditors were procured by
national tender exercise organized by
the public sector audit appointments by
otherwise known as psaa
the vast majority of the councils within
the england participate in this tender
exercise the torrid we were grant farms
and were appointed as our external
auditors
the audit of the account for the
financial year
2022-23 because their last year become
contracts
so the options to available to storage
are
on its own or in partnership with all
the local authorities contender for
external audit services or it could opt
into the next national procurement of
external audit services to the
commission by the psa
if we were to commission on its own and
it would be on our own because there's
no appetite within the devon authorities
to do a joint procurement exercise
we'd have to set up an audit panel to
undertake the tenderness and evaluate
the performance against the contract the
panel would have to have a majority of
non-elected members
and we've experienced an account of
difficulty in recruiting non-elected
members
it would be resource intensive and
without the purchasing power of the
national tender exercise it would be
unlikely
that we would get very likely that we
get a more expensive option
therefore it is requested that full
council tonight endorse the
recommendation from order and governance
of the 18th of january the torres
council opts into the national
procurement tender and just for
information
and the pssa need a note from full
council in order for us to opt in so
it's required that you
formally recommend that the torres
district council opts into the national
public external line of services i have
to take any questions or recommendations
uh we'll have our handle first
thank you i'm not wishing to um steal
the thunder from the chair of audit
whose hand also went up but a little bit
after my but as lead member for finance
i would like to make this proposal
a recommendation
i would not want to
exceed my role but
as was said by our 151 officer we've
discussed it at audit governance it has
to be sorted out by the 11th of march
and if we were to go on our own we would
be incurring a risk
and
a greater cost
as my partner he was pointed out so i'm
happy to second thank you and the other
speakers
okay it's been proposed and seconded i'm
sure of hands for all in support
[Music]
seeks your approval to add the cost of
the
new ice machines to the capital program
for 21.22
so the ice machine that we currently
have that outdoor fish stock has become
highly efficient costs around 7000
pounds a year to maintain and it also
doesn't produce ice of sufficient
quality
to help the tenants and users of the
fish stock so we've made applications
the mmo and been successful with a
two-thirds grant so we've been offered
twenty two thousand pounds towards a
thirty three thousand pennsylvania so
that leads me with the recommendation
that we added to the capital program
this is some fresh ice a little frozen
device
quite nicely
well not a nice expert here but
i think it's
any other questions
[Music]
do you want to speak just a very brief
um comment
i know it's not in the report but i know
the fishermen have got concerns about
the diesel tank
i know it's under consideration at the
moment but i hope this can be
satisfactory
[Music]
in favor
[Music]
okay there's a couple of few members of
staff that are going to leave whilst
this item is presented
[Music]
the hr manager sarah anders will present
the report sarah thank you chair
so um section 38 of the legalism act
2011 requires english and welsh local
authorities to produce a statutory pay
policy statement each financial year
the principle is to increase
accountability transparency and fairness
in the setting of local pay
the pay policy applies to those officers
whose terms and conditions reflect those
determined by the joint negotiating
committee for chief officers
so at torridge those officers are the
chief executive
the head of communities in place head of
legal and governance and finance manager
in section 151 officer
the pay for these officers was set as
part of the management restructuring
2020
and with external advice from southwest
councils and there have been no
amendments since
the hutton reporting in 2011 on fair pay
in the public sector determined the most
appropriate metric for calculating pay
dispersion is multiple of chief
executive to median earnings
should this be greater than 10 this will
be reported by the leader to full
council the current pay multiple is 6.1
it's a requirement to publish the agreed
pay statement on the council's website
and this needs to be approved by full
council by the 31st march each year
you said okay
[Music]
so we said
this is the same thing as this last year
the
multiple is well below the
recommendation that doesn't mean to say
we're going to pay any more money to
anyone
but it's a solid
statement that we need to do every year
as i say it's the same it's asking you
so i just recommend that we adopt it
don't really recommend it
all right let me just go second question
okay
[Music]
okay uh sure fans are all in favor
thank you
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
the lead member which is captured
what it says
it's just a vacancy um occurred the lead
member of uh legal and democratic
services
um i'd just like to praise the
current or the previous lead member
councillor hurley for his work over the
time um i've got a lot more jobs for him
to do so he will be concentrating on
other stuff
so i'd just like to move on i can
recommend
um
that we
asked coach newton to step into that
role
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
there are no petitions item 18 notice a
motion
and one received from councillor brenton
um
over here
thank you chair
well um fellow councillors i'm uh i find
this uh quite depressing actually that i
brought forward this emotion
i was thinking back over 40 years ago i
got involved with
local government politics
and that was thanks to southwest water
as they put proposals forward for the
fine screen works upstream from the from
biddeford
which would have resulted in a nice
sewage flow going through bitter very
times and we thought that we took them
on
and we won
and we thought well water quality would
improve
last week's gazette
from page on the crustable weight
and it sounded wonderful here
how
bathing water quality was excellent
sounds good until you do your homework
and then you find that actually their
sampling they only have to do
nine in the course of a year
from the same spot on the beach
and of those nine
two of them the worst two you can
discount
so hence
not surprisingly you do get a good
result that was not how it was done
under the european water corrections
because we're no longer a part of europe
so we get away with anything now
basically that seems to be the rule it
also poses a question
why is it
that the dirty water that's coming out
of the torridge and the tour
which ends up in biddeford bay
is excellent quality well we know that's
not the case well
we hope when this uh
this goes to ons and i hope ons will
actually take this on and drag in the
environment agency and southwest water
and start asking some serious questions
for them how they're doing their
monitoring and what's actually happening
because
this stove beach for example used to be
bathing water and it used to fail quite
frequently it failed so much that it no
longer is a bathing beach
it isn't remaining beach anymore our
shellfish are
regularly condemned because of the
pollution in the water
so how does that water get out into the
bay and our westward home house is
excellent
anybody who's studied the dye tests that
have been done in bitter bay
and notice a sort of swirling
arrangement
and help and start asking questions
we'll talk to some of the surface out
there for example but other people have
regulated
bathing now in the sea in wild water and
fresh water is becoming increasingly
popular
we need to ensure
that our river quality water
and our bathing water is of the highest
standard not by some separate
new criteria
so there are a huge amount of questions
to answer i would like ons to look at
this
ask those questions
because there is no monitoring service
seemingly overseas order at the moment
you've got water council
which is uh very difficult to trace on
even darnell are not very good at
instead being so
even somebody
an idiot like me should go i know what
they're up to and i can't before that
there was a water voice
which i was a member of there but the
government scrapper
basically i think we're doing our job
too well really they've got embarrassing
water companies and the environment
agency over there in attitude
so
i needed you to um
or not they should go forward thank you
thank you
thanks brandon because
we wish to speak on this one
i do realize i don't have the wrong
fleece
it's the warmest i have and it can be
quite chilly in here i don't really work
there
um
just in response to councillor brenton
we do actually have this on the forward
plan
of overview and speeding on the external
committee i think it's june
from eight or april even quicker than
what i thought so um karen
and
janet and myself are working together to
get contacting from these relevant
agencies that we can put these questions
to
um this has been on the board planned
for quite some time and we're only just
getting there we seem to have gotten
extremely busy on overview of the
schools to me external at the moment but
april is
um
i would suggest a couple of things
about eight years ago ten years ago
there was a joint working group set up
between north devon and torridge
which i chaired and frank biedemann
chaired it when it was over in the civic
center and we looked at this we had the
environment agency here we had
southwest water
and your first question how many
incidents that permitted discharge
the problem there's a huge problem here
because we couldn't quite believe we
asked them about
private licenses to discharge into the
river and it sticks in my memory and i
have to go back to the minute there was
something like 264
private licenses and i said oh you
monitor those then no
do you think so anyone could be dumping
anything in there to be honest um it
might be worth trying to find those
minutes because we did quite a lot of
work on that
um
the second thing is uh
the
um
environment agency
this was in the paper on saturday i'll
give it to you if you like i'll just
read out one bit between 2013 and 2018
monitoring of water quality in fresh
water environments was halved
from 10 797 sites to 4
4656
this is the environment agency's own
figures
and this is our leader it said that uh
farmers can only expect to visit from an
environment agency officer testing on
water quality on average once every 263
years
so you're all right ken
but it's an absolutely fascinating
article and prosecutions
for water
pollution
in the decades of 2020 formed
dramatically
uh there were 235 in 2002
in 2020 there were three
[Music]
to do with a
process there
are they still i would like to
have it registered if you ask the
environmental agency
um
is the point of discharge in the
[Music]
we have
you know i look forward to hearing
wellness in the future
okay
so it's been proposed by council branton
seconded by country christie our shelf
has all in favor
[Music]
19 and 20 have been struck off the
agenda because we're remaining in part
one so we'll go down in 21
uh recommendations from the standards
committee on the 5th of january 22 ages
120 to 124.
no station
i was going to keep this relatively
brief but
this is the first time tonight that this
has been in the public arena
um
the reason being is because
um many of the complaints had emanated
from um private individuals and
in accordance with our constitution we
we've kept their identity
private and will still remain to keep
their identity private but just to give
some background um information
um in march
last year um i as monitoring officer for
the council began receiving um
complaints against
councillor
leonard ford
in relation to various incidents that
had occurred
[Music]
in relation to
threatening abusive and behavior um both
at public places uh both um one
complainant home address and and that
abusive behavior was occurring through
um emails and other literature that was
being put up around the torridge area
and so generally speaking when i receive
complaints as a monitoring officer
um i refer all of those complaints to
the
member for a response because as you all
know um once a complaint is made um that
member is entitled to see those
complaints and fully answer those
complaints
which is what occurred in in this
instance
now i would generally investigate or
appoint an investigative officer which
would be the deputy monitoring officer
um but in this case that wasn't possible
because
after the complaints came in about
councillor ford he then submitted
complaints against myself and others of
us on the senior management team
and for that reason we needed someone
who was mutual and independent to the
process
so we approached the local government
association who made recommendations in
relation to
someone who could independently
investigate
that and
jack hegarty was appointed
and that was done in agreement with
councilman ford he was quite happy with
him um as an independent person
so um the information was handed over to
jack
um councilman ford was interviewed and
he did
speak to the independent investigator
and then um
the investigator interviewed all
complainants
those notes were sent to councillor ford
and the complainants were checking to
check that it was an accurate recording
of the investigation in the meeting and
it was at that stage that um councillor
ford decided that he wasn't going to
have any other involvement with the
process
um he had the opportunity to dispute the
allegations to attend the standards
committee to raise any information in
relation to
the evidence that was submitted to him
and he chose not to do so
um
just guru also and it wasn't my report
that was um submitted to the standards
committee it was the independent
investigators so after i handed over all
the information i had no further
involvement uh with that that case
because of the allegations that were
made against me during that process
um and i also made it very clear to
councillor ford that if he had
allegations to make agreements for me or
any of the senior officers within this
room then he could
speak to the investigator and that would
feed into the process
okay so um we convened the standards
committee on the 4th of august
and the standards committee made
determinations in relation to the
allegations
um
they found that he had
displayed threatening intimidating and
verbally abusive behavior both in person
and public places
um
and i just want to also add that as a
result of the accusations made against
his council this council was also
threatened with legal action
due to it because um it was one of our
councillors and
the public were asking if tories were
sanctioning and that that behavior
so the hearing went ahead on the fourth
of august um councillor ford had chosen
not to attend that hearing process and
the determinations were made
um
standards committee
resolved to ask councillor ford to
write written apologies to the
complainants
and to some of the complainants who he
had admitted during the course of uh the
investigation where his that his
behavior had fallen far short of what
was expected
in addition standards committee made a
recommendation to full council
that he'd be excluded from the council
premises
so that was referred to full council and
as you probably remember
that was um carried by fall council
um
following the standards hearing um
councillor ford has refused to apologize
to any of the complainants and has made
it clear that he has no intention of
doing so
so at the direction of the standards
committee the mata was referred back to
standards on the fifth of january this
year
who have made the following
recommendation that the matter be
brought into the public domain for the
purposes of
publication
of the findings of that committee and as
members will see on page one two three
there is a draft uh press release should
members be reminded to approve that
i'm happy to take any
this
questions
is to
approve or not the recommendations for
the standards committee and to bring the
matter into
the public meeting we've done that so
we're presumably not recommending that
the recommendations i mean it was in
part b
am i right
well
actually
yeah it was in um part two but as
members will know earlier on on the
agenda and was voted to bring it into a
part one
meeting
and but there was still the subject of
the um press release attached to that
page one two three and following on from
standards committee recommendations
[Music]
i propose an amendment to the
recommendation
from standards committee that we have
before us
councillor ford has consistently abused
the official email account
provided for him by torridge district
council
he has used the system to make numerous
unsubstantiated and intimidating
allegations against members and officers
alike
corroborated by the independent
standards committee investigation
he has used his official torridge
district council email account to lobby
private citizens who were not members or
officers of the council as well as
releasing sensitive council information
to unauthorized persons again
corroborated by the independent
standards committee investigation
he has ignored sanctions imposed upon
him by this council for earlier abuses
when he used his official torres
district council email account to harass
members and officers in an intimidating
manner
as part of his relentless campaign of
unsubstantiated but highly intimidating
allegations against members and officers
councillor ford has in effect
weaponized the torridge district council
email system to an extent where the
efficiency
and reputation of the council has been
placed at risk
the time has now come to stop such
misuse of the official torridge district
council email system and the
intimidation and distress that such
abuse is causing
i therefore move that the following
sanction be added to that already
recommended by standards committee
in accordance with a range of sanctions
available to this council
specifically that concerning the
withdrawal of certain facilities
provided
to a councillor by the council
councillor ford's torridge district
council email account is to be closed
with immediate effect for a period of
six months followed by review
i mean
thank you
i would just like to support
those comments made by councilman
because i've been one of the counsellors
who received numerous emails which i can
only describe as indecipherable ranks
we have offices
of unquestionable probity here who've
not been allowed
to speak for themselves
and i would just like to wholeheartedly
support the dignified way that our
officers
have presented themselves throughout
this
whole vindictive campaign
i think james wants to speak
i'll keep my very brief
um because i'm subject to a lot of the
abuse i will fully support what person
ewing has just proposed but i will ask
my deputy to second
i definitely got to set in that notion
because i am the subject of the abuse
just before we get to that
councilman
thank you chair um
i do support councillor newton's
statement i'm just wondering whether the
six months is long enough i shouldn't
think it should be till the end of
return
until may 23 april 23
and that leads me to question how is he
actually serving his constituents how is
he actually and
it is acknowledged that we all receive
an allowance
to help us
do our work
before i get to your council meeting
or something um sorry i thought you'd
[Music]
uh that's finish what counselor newton
has said
i do think we need to add on that he
will receive all relevant counsel uh
information
in hard mail
because we don't have the power to
remove any of our responsibilities for
any counsellor so
all correspondence be hard mail not we
take away the the laptop and i think
actually we get an allowance don't do it
for coin electronics so that's
[Music]
first of all to cancer council manly
i share her sentiment however i think we
need to be proportionate and six months
followed by review then we can readdress
the situation in six months that isn't
saying that it isn't doesn't continue if
the situation is no better or we don't
see any any reason uh to to grant back
uh the email account uh councillor
brenton um
my recommendation is purely the
suspension of its email account it is
not that he be taken off the modern.gov
system so or withdrawal of his ipad so
he would still have electronic access to
all council papers etcetera because
otherwise we would be placing an
additional burden on staff having to
think and it's purely the email account
that i'm proposing being closed
thank you
[Music]
the box in the chair i'd like to second
cancel the newton's version and indulge
everything that he has said tonight
um
i have been party to this but
uh not to the same extent as some of my
fellow councillors and certainly not to
any extent that our offices have endured
and it is not appropriate
we have a duty of care
to everyone to each other
and to our serving staff
so thank you thank you
country christie first name comes from
norway yes um
i don't mind
this at all but
when i get messages they come from his
iphone they don't come with his ipad you
can suspend this thing but all our email
addresses are online we could go he
could contact us anyway so suspending
that doesn't seem to do anything
it makes it personal not official so
first of all he's not sending out an
official
uh something official on a torrid email
secondly he doesn't have an all
councillors button
can you unlock and then catch the laws
with that particular point then we added
to the public press statement so
everyone in the public knows that as
well
that's a good point
station would like to reply to that one
that's what full council determines
tonight we can amend a press statement
to to reflect that decision i'd like to
propose then that we do
some laws you're going to speak
yes i would just like to pass on my
sincere thanks to my committee
and to the officers
this has been a very pleasant episode
for anybody
and
that's all i can do is pass on my thanks
and from here
no more dance
counselor
thank you very much mr chairman just a
thought um can we as
individuals block
another individual on our email account
so if we didn't want to receive
messages
are we allowed
[Music]
now
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
okay i think the summary is that
councillor ford's email toriage.gov
email account is removed
and that the press statement is updated
to that effect
yeah it's a basic recommendation to
making the standard committee's
um
collaborations publicly recommendations
plus the email bit correct
so just like just slightly uneasy
really about
councillor ford representing his um
his ward in
[Music]
i know april
appears very hasn't recently it's been a
lot of rounds but
he was still elected by apple
and uh
you know to cut off
[Music]
and i just would like to put that in the
balance well i think that's the whole
point of making this public presumably
this this piece will be put in local
press this left will be a local brand so
local residents in his ward that he's
meant to be represented will know
exactly
what the situation is and i think that
is you know that's critical here
continues
once more in answer to to that very good
point council
the apple door returned to ward members
and therefore there is still a ward
member behind me here he may not thank
me for pointing out as such and he will
remain very much on the council email
and therefore nobody is going
unrepresented because everybody in
appledore can't necessarily come through
councillor hate who was equally um in
fact i think he was he i think
we were
a counselor
sorry
yeah so actually the number one choice
is here behind me and they should go
there first
okay well it's been prepared i'm sorry
um as to where the residents can go
for help
you know we we know she is announced but
somebody a lay person who just wants
help with a problem
needs a reference on the appropriate
[Music]
um obviously council of pennant have
made reference so councillor ford is
still the elected member or one of the
elected members for that ward and there
was in the original sanctions uh that
was recognized at the standards meeting
which is why
there was provision put in that council
ford contacts myself
for any dealings that he needs to have
with residents and issues within babylon
so you're not changing that part of the
sanction that still
remains this is about the i.t system
so there would be no need to publicize
everybody
in our
[Music]
well i was going to say to council adult
that there's still two members for apple
law and people who live in apple door
can contact either of them
the fact that he won't have an email
storage email
really it's neither here there they know
where he lives in alberta i'm sure
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay but it's been proposed by coaster
newton
seconded by coaster hodgson
that report as detailed by the
monitoring officer
the implemented can have a shorthand
[Music]
whether those people involved in what
has been going on should be voting on
this
we do have an interest
well i would have thought they would be
more than
more than entitled to vote or not
personally but um you know
some people had obviously far more abuse
than what others did i mean i was a
recipient of quite a few
messages
[Music]
and phone messages suddenly lunchtime
so i'm quite happy to understand the
vote yeah um as i did in february
so it has my forces
[Music]
well i think we'll understand what we're
actually voting on is the fact that you
know he hasn't complied with the
sanctions that the standards committee
imposed on him i.e you know the
apologies et cetera et cetera he hasn't
done any of those it's really that what
we're focusing on here rather than him
as an individual the same would happen
if it was any counsellor so i have a one
intention
so it's been proposed and it's been
seconded
so
the show fans all in support
[Music]
i think that is the correct vote
because it shows you know solidarity and
that we're all coming at this from
exactly the same position
[Music]
brings the meeting to an end at
13 minutes per second thank you very
much